welcome back to the iced coffee hour
i got margin called no you didn't no you
did not yeah i did what yeah no i i
don't believe you much marginally i
don't believe jack i don't believe jack
no he i think he's being serious i don't
know no i don't think so no i did
yeah i don't hold on to robin hood
anymore
i don't believe you wait okay good job
i'm not believe i'm not i think jack is
joking believe me man what would people
say if just like look you work with with
me and they're like oh yeah graham's
co-host got margin called i mean how
does it i mean you've got to think of
this i mean i also have margin
you guys do it
are you guys you guys are missing okay
so i know you know i think you're
messing so here's what happened
basically i opened up a robin hood
account i have an m1 account i have a
vanguard account those are what i use
predominantly for index fund investing
which when i first was getting started
was like 85 to 90 of my portfolio
i invested i think it was i think it was
20
principal in my robin hood account when
i was like you know what i want to try
trading out random stocks and like
selling options and doing all of that
like crazy stuff right not selling
options i still stand by it's not crazy
but i wanted to do options in like
individual stocks and stuff like that
and uh i grew that account very fast
with like dogecoin selling options and
the market was very it wasn't a bull run
and i was
doing really well off of that and i
brought it all the way up to 75 000 the
20 thousand dollars in probably a year
or so time
now
this is where you're a genius jack
i know i know right this is where i
messed up uh that's seventy
thousand dollars seventy five thousand
dollars or whatever i had not used
margin yet
and i was like you know what you know
this is a good idea why not use margin
if i'm picking out the stocks that have
brought me to 75 000 just to put a
little bit more in them so i decided to
do that
one of them was
robin hood which
famously graham told me not to invest in
my gosh
and uh then it plummeted so i went in on
margin and i bought some robin hood
stock and then the market started going
down and it continued to go down and uh
yeah i got margin called because of
robin hood because of robert
robin yeah robin has gone oh wait all of
it yeah yes yes
we got to buy in right now and i say 500
bucks jack i was i was willing to pay
for those who don't know here's the bad
story i was at the gym how are you happy
man because you finally sold because you
finally sold robin hood i have been on
you for months to sell robinhood stock
yeah since it was like
30 dollars i'm like sell 20 sell 17 i
offered you 500 bucks to sell robinhood
17 i'd pay you and then last night i
said how about this i'll pay you another
500 bucks right now to sell your robin
hood stock maybe he didn't take because
he knew he couldn't tell no because it
was he was already margin no you would
have been margin called today because
robin hood was down another six percent
anyways i got margin called and uh you
know it is what it is i'm fine with it
because in the beginning it started out
as play money it grew to a really
sizable amount so yeah i was dumb by not
selling like when i was at 30 40 50 60
70 whatever account value but i just
kind of held i decided to diamond hands
and hodl but if you think you're the
exception guess what you're probably not
uh just like i thought i was wait why
are you saying that just because you
can't do it other people can't do it
probably no you're saying you're the
pinnacle investor or no i'm saying
because i couldn't do it i'm just going
to probably it's like the scariest part
is when i had the monkey pick random
stocks and the monkey made 40 in a year
that's a sign that like hey guys maybe
we should let's go back a monkey
picking stocks out of a container i mean
that's that's what we're dealing with
here and everyone's an expert when you
look at the amount of finance channels
that popped up in 2020 and everybody was
oh i'm playing this and playing
everyone's making money every day i'm
becoming more and more like dave ramsey
when we listened to him speak the other
day he came to las vegas and did that
and tell people about that yeah so he
came to las vegas and i confronted dave
ramsey in person yeah i confronted him
yeah he's really nice but really nice
guy really nice guy but he gave this
incredibles like speech or he was
talking for basically an hour and when
he came on stage i was like
mesmerized just like first of all i'm
star struck i'm like that that's him
like to see him on set like he's right
there show the footage right here yeah
yeah i was blown away that like that's
him but he's better in person on stage
than he is in his videos
no comparison at all but in the video or
or sorry on stage he brought up these
props and he talked about like the tulip
mania and just like all the bubbles
along the way and california goldbridge
the gold rush that was really
interesting uh real estate tech stocks
he covered he covered everything
and um people get excited over these
fads right and they think that they're
the exception nfts you think that you
can make a lot of money and some people
do and that's the loud minority and then
other people they limp in yeah they
think that they're good they think
they're calling babies too
beanie babies yeah that's another one
and then you get burned like i did on
margin yeah but his thing was that uh
you're never the exception
this time is never different and it's
the same thing repeating itself over and
over and over again and it will
eventually crash to zero the market will
always
go back to the mean and will continue on
so you have you know the market trending
upwards but you have a lot of that in
between and i think 2020 was that in
between i mean
so i think it just goes to show
index funds it does it's like the same
buy and hold strategy and that's why it
bothers me though now i'm i'm finally
feeling good about it because for the
last throughout 2020 2021
everyone is like graham you say the same
things every video the same thing just
buy and hold buy and hold index funds
and uh because it's become a joke now
what do you do and when the greatest
wealth transfer is coming
buy and hold an index fund i mean that's
it even we joke about it right now like
let me guess the ending of the video
graham buy and hold index [ __ ] yeah you
know yeah but it's the truth and it
works so what what happened what what so
you started with twenty five on margin
i bought a bunch of apple stock because
i was like it's apple it'll be fine and
it was yeah but what wasn't fun was my
robin hood stock my palantir stuff
which i went so heavy on unfortunately
but i was making a lot of money on it
that's the thing i was making so much
money like you know what i have access
to all of this margin may as well just
put it back into all this stuff and then
everything plummets so what's your
portfolio account at now take a guess
well okay so i'll give you i'll give you
you say one number and i'll tell you
over under and i will give you one well
you started with
get twenty number yep yeah and its peak
was 75. 75. okay 45. graham
i'm going to say 18.
under
wow yeah are you it was wow are you
joking no pure obliteration in my
portfolio fortunately fortunately that
was still like i said
a minority of my investments
vast majority in index funds roth ira
just dropping exactly haven't you
learned anything i feel like we've spent
so much time together that you wouldn't
know but all of my losses were basically
unrealized gain
it's not like it was actual profit i had
never sold anything yep but you started
your but you started your account at 25.
yeah so i had a little bit of obviously
like principle that i lost yeah that's
the good thing with dave ramsey i will
say is everything he says won't get
anyone in trouble like no one could ever
be like oh i paid off my mortgage early
and then i lost it like right yeah so
it'll never come back to bite dave
ramsey even though he's overly safe
he'll never get in trouble by saying
that
i think it's so funny when when we were
watching him and he just takes time to
pause and he just chuckles like about
something oh yeah yeah like people on
this robin hood
it was a longer positive the crypto
currency
[Music]
he commanded the room he commanded the
reminder the room was silent yeah when
he went up there yeah
really i i liked it a lot i'd actually
go back and and watch him again at first
i went into it thinking oh i know all of
this this is going to be silly and then
listening to him like this is really
good you know i feel like i'm learning
stuff we so graham got invited he didn't
mention this but you got invited by one
of the people on dave ramsey's george
george yeah so we
not for anything like entitlement-wise
but like graham kind of assumed maybe
there was some special stages backstage
thing
no it was a meet and greet and we like
we went in the same lines everyone else
did we showed you we're at the end of
the line yeah
no we're at the end of the lines we're
at the far back end of the of the uh
whatever you call it the auditorium was
that the first meet and greet you've
ever been to or have you been to another
i've never been to a meet and greet so
your only meet and greet was to meet
dave ramsey yeah that's cool but it was
funny because we showed up and graham's
like i wonder if he'll recognize me like
i feel like like
graham and i were like yeah he probably
will recognize you just because you're
you're just you're so successful in this
space
didn't look like you reckon i don't
think so i mean in his defense a lot of
people are coming through
maybe he could have but didn't want to
like you know on stage or sometimes
you're like there's so many people
coming in that like you just look at
them halfway like yeah you're like
you're basically like tunnel vision and
they're like oh they can't like come
this way and then the camera and then
you know
you that also could be yes uh he also is
probably not on youtube so honestly i
wouldn't be shocked if he didn't
recognize you i have i'm like 80 sure
didn't recognize me yeah but but the
weird thing is he did comment but then
again someone else could have access to
his youtube account because he did
comment on one of our videos yeah i
don't think that's dave ramsey
realistically he probably has an entire
team not a bad idea um by the way
taking care of his youtube account and
doing all that stuff and he just shows
up and people are like we're gonna have
people call in you're gonna talk to him
or just discuss this financial event and
he does
so
i like him a lot yeah that was great
like dave ramsey but first i want to
thank our sponsor grammarly being a
creator is exhausting writing scripts
emails and text messages it's just
really time consuming yes but thankfully
we have grammarly grammarly is an
all-in-one writing tool that helps you
communicate clearly and effectively even
when you're short on time ever since we
installed grammarly on our work
computers we've been able to save
countless hours and put our focus back
on the work that matters the most making
content grammarly is like having a
professional writer looking through your
work 24 7. the free version is also
amazing since it protects you from the
basic spelling grammar phrasing and
punctuation but the real magic happens
when you upgrade to grammarly premium
grammarly premium offers clarity
suggestions and even full sentence
rewrites to help you clearly convey your
message and avoid miscommunication
grammarly even has a built-in tone
detector that can help you sound as
confident professional or as formal as
you need they also have vocab
suggestions to replace overly used words
phrases and words so get through those
emails and your work quicker by keeping
it concise confident and effective with
grammarly so go to grammarly.com iced
coffee and sign up for a free account
and when you're ready to upgrade to
premium you can get 20 off just for
being a listener that's 20 off www
dot g r a m m a
r l y dot com slash iced coffee thank
you so much grammarly and back to the
until now
what are you doing tomorrow graham
flying to tampa why are you flying to
tampa why am i i got to fight i got that
i'm going to be so happy to get it over
with dude what are your thoughts right
now you're about to fight one of the
largest tech creators michael reeves
he's your same height same weight no
we're not the same weight so
uh ian sent me a text this morning said
michael weighed in at 120. what are you
waiting for 127.4 that's good for you
though that's good for you i don't know
if because i don't know how it works
because i know there are different
weight classes from like 120 125 125 you
don't know the ranges i told ian i'm i i
i'm ranging between 125 and 130 i always
have he's like don't worry that'll be
fine
and so i don't know if i have to get
down to 125 to be in his
weight range i send it to ian he's like
oh no worries we'll tell him to drink
some more shakes or something like that
so drink some more shakes yeah i
wouldn't worry too much about it if yeah
if anything since you guys are at the at
the light weight it's easier for him to
come up probably like a pound or two
yeah uh probably that's my guess graham
what what do you think are the chances
you win
versus him you know what sucks man is i
had a i actually did like a i don't want
to say a deep talk with with macy last
night but i feel like i put myself down
so often with this that i've mentally
just kind of screwed myself in the fight
i i got way too in my head once i
started watching videos of him boxing i
constantly just like put myself down i'm
not training enough i'm not good enough
and i worry that's going to come through
in the fight in just the way because
anyone who who succeeds stuff like that
they never think of that stuff they're
always just like no i'm gonna i'm just
gonna do it and you have that confidence
that makes you do it i'm worried at this
point i i have not but you know what i
saw a huge spark once you did sparring
with somebody you did not know and even
more when you told me you got a bloody
nose yeah because here's the thing
this is a person that you do not know
that you were sparring i saw that you
kind of had
more of an uplift and i i agree i know
what you mean you put yourself down a
little bit
um but after that i think
i saw your confidence go up
significantly i'm more confident after
that but it's easier for me to fight
somebody i didn't know because i don't
feel as bad oh his name is brian by the
way we fought but i don't feel as bad
hurting brian because
i just recently met him i like him but
if if i hurt him let's just say it's not
like i've known him for years
or it's in front of all these people who
are fans of brian
if i do something to michael reeves
you know i don't want to i think i don't
think it's cool
like i just hate hurting anybody you
know i honestly i told my mom this
because she's like how do you think he's
gonna do and i'm like i think i'll do
well but the one thing it's hard for me
to wrap my head around is picturing this
in my mind graham and michael in the
ring michael let's say just got hit in
the face or something or he kind of
slipped dropped his hand for a second
and he has his eyes and he's looking at
graham and he's kind of like dazed maybe
yeah and graham going and just hitting
him i could never picture but i have to
do that i know you are such a softy and
i mean that and the most positive that's
true you are a very positive way because
i admire that because i'm a softy too
yeah so that's that's what i worry about
but also it's it's so i have to overcome
two things hurting somebody else
and
believing that i could do it and it's
just tough one thing that ian said when
we had him on the podcast was that
what you could do since it's five rounds
is you could struggle through three and
then on that fourth round just decide
that hey i'm gonna go in i'm gonna
attack i'm gonna be offensive and i'm
gonna really get in there and do my best
and then you could completely change it
around in one room right like just
because the first three rounds have been
bad for you doesn't mean the fourth one
has to be and i feel like that that
could apply to the first the second the
third the fourth or fifth round and just
your overall mentality it's like just
because you've thought that for a while
doesn't mean you could just you know
switch around it will be hard
maybe i mean we'll see so what do you do
if you win what do you do if you lose
what does it change anything ah i would
probably have some regrets if i lost
only because uh
i probably could have pushed myself
further harder does that mean you would
be considering getting in the ring again
no
this is a one-off one-off thing so
either way either way if i win it would
be incredible but i but then i feel bad
winning at the expense of michael you
know but how do you think he feels i
honestly i think michael is just having
fun i don't i don't think he's thinking
this through i think he's just doing it
and that's what worries me so why can't
you do this yeah why can't you do the
same man i don't know power through it
i don't know because here's the thing
realistically let's say you hit michael
a little bit too hard gave him a bloody
nose
i feel like he i feel like afterwards
he'd be like dude you got such a good
shot like after i met michael like i
feel like that's his personality and he
knows it's all and i would i would do
that i would say the same thing to him i
mean brian hit me right in the face
right in the draw he got one like this
yeah
and after i was like man good good one
it's you know but yeah i mean you know
it's about respect and as long as you
guys both respect each other
why not try your hardest yeah okay
i know i part of me wants to get um
what is it called like uh like hypnosis
and like just pay someone to to like put
me under
and then hypnotize me have you been
hypnotized before no i have does that
actually work i think i think yeah i've
never looked into the to the science
behind it but i'll be honest i'm a i've
looked into
specific types of hypnosis when i used
to do magic but that's very different
than like hypnotherapy or whatever they
call it uh so i don't know i'm pretty
skeptical on it but tell me about your
experience yeah my experience with
hypnosis so i went to the state fair i
think i was probably 17 or 18 at the
time state fair yeah and they would have
they would have these people that would
come up and perform on this like that on
this platform get an audience and
everything and then like every night at
8pm they'd have like the hypnotist and
if you go in the audience and you're
lucky they pick you out of the audience
to participate in her act right so i was
one of 40 people or 30 people that she
brought up on the stage and we all sat
on these chairs she started doing this
weird i don't know if she actually did
that that i don't remember was like six
years ago but she started like talking
in a very quiet and monotone tone and
she was like oh you're feeling very
sleepy she gets her heart rate down a
lot and then she walks to everybody
that's lined up in these chairs on the
on the stage and she grabs your arm and
then drops it and that's how she can
tell if you are hypnotized or not
because like some people leave their arm
up there and it's like clear okay you're
not hypnotized if you leave your arm up
there or if you like bring it down
really hard yourself or if she sees
movement she wants to see like a very
relaxed fall of your arm basically to
see if you're hypnotized apparently i
was hypnotized because she kept me up on
the stage she sent probably the other
half down and then she instructed me to
dance with someone and
i usually would have a little bit of
trouble doing that just because it's in
front of an audience and maybe i'll get
a little nervous or something like that
but it was very easy when i was
hypnotized hypnotized they basically
make you not care what anybody thinks
and it's not necessarily control i feel
like i could have
not obeyed what she had told me to do
but i was in such an easy going mental
state that it was like why not why not
do what she told me to do and that was
my experience with it it's like she
wasn't directly controlling me but also
she wasn't like not controlling me at
all because i did what she said i heard
yeah i heard with that kind of stuff you
would never do something that you
wouldn't normally
be like if you were against something
that you wouldn't do it even if you're
hit i probably there were certain things
if she had she requested me to do them i
could have taken off your shirt yeah i
could have rejected that
i wouldn't have rejected that
but
maybe it works yeah maybe yeah but hey
oh yeah you're worth looking into maybe
i don't know
graham
are you doing okay man you just seem
really stressed yeah man yeah you seem a
little out of it
no just because we're talking about the
boxing that's oh okay
i know also this this recent drop in the
stock market has been affecting you a
little bit in your portfolio
because he told us
like i may have lost you know 60 grand
or whatever but at the same time how
much did were you down of realized or
unrealized gain
uh
probably one and a half million oh my
gosh from the peak then and you said at
that point when you were down one and a
half million you were up fifty thousand
dollars of unrealized games right from
when you started investing yeah because
uh i had dollar i basically started
upping
since about a year ago maybe a little
over a year ago so it was hopping
yeah yeah so
because i was making a little bit more i
started investing heavier
just on a regular basis but obviously
you're buying all the way up and then
buying all the way back down
so um yeah negative like 300 grand 250.
you're negative 300 yeah no so your
overall experience with stock market
investing is you would have been better
off holding it in cash um it's hard to
say because they have certain tax lots
that oh yeah are that makes sense
positive and certain or negative so it's
hard to say like if you pointed right
now and said that
you could always look in hindsight and
say i'd be better off doing that or this
but um you know i'm not bothered by it i
think right now i'm down like
two percent three percent four
somewhere which in the big picture it's
not uh you did the right thing
technically i mean you dollar cost
averaging broad index funds there's
nothing wrong with that
yeah oh the other the other negative was
that um
i sold off
a good chunk in december to tax loss
harvest so i sold that and then i put
that chunk
into the s p
on january 2nd third like it was after
the new year yeah
yeah god because i
because that was probably in individual
stocks which plummeted a lot more than
the smp right that's true but yeah
yeah and what does this all taught you
all of this crazy market turbulence and
everything the same it's just
the same same thing yeah i think if
anything real estate feels better
because you don't see the fluctuations
so if there is a loss it doesn't really
matter as long as it doesn't affect your
actions correct it's harder to sell and
it prevents that impulsive decision to
be like oh i'm going to just click a
button and sell it's a lot easier with
stocks so with real estate when you're
renting them out it doesn't really
matter
so i wasn't going to sell anyway so as
long as it rented that's fine how about
ulx how has this changed your
perspective what's the entire market
yeah uh honestly it hasn't really
changed my perspective
i i literally just invest into the s p
500 that's it um but i'm i mentioned
yesterday on millennial money i'm at a
point where i'm considering pulling out
some money uh just because we're looking
to buy a house within the next
year and a half to two years
but i'm going to wait until
we kind of have a set
time and then we'll make the decision
then so
just because
even though i would be pulling out i
wouldn't say like a loss but like
you know we're down yeah um it's still
better for me um to have that money and
know that
that it's there for the down payment for
all the fees um and just be safe rather
than to leave it into the market that
makes sense yeah so
yeah other than that no not not really
changing anything
i haven't bought any individual stocks
and probably um well he i should say
huge amounts of big socks since like i
bought netflix and i got pummeled with
netflix netflix but i'm holding i'm
holding
yeah what can you do now is the easy
part i'm gonna say like this is the
not worry part imagine if it's another
50 down from here
i can't imagine 40 down
i don't have any individual stocks
anymore i know but but even
what are you kidding but even
everything put it in it even index funds
jack let's just say it goes down another
40 for right now
there's nothing that says we can't hit
2800. i'm building up uh cash position
right now and i'm not investing it yet i
know i could continue averaging as the
stock market's going down but i would
way rather just hold it in cash right
now that's it
i didn't sell stock and hold it in cash
i'm leaving all of my invested money
invested but my income i'm just building
cash i'm considering building up a
higher cash position as well um i have
right now about uh
four months of emergency fun um but i'm
considering building that out to six
um
just because i want to be
like
i don't know with with the way the last
week has been my life has been a little
bit crazy i had a pet pass away and and
stuff like that and um i don't know like
i i like i just i feel like there's a
bigger sense of me to just prepare for
like the unexpected you know because you
don't expect stuff like that and part of
me feels like i should build it up to
six but realistically between four and
six what do you guys think do you think
that really makes a difference to build
up an emergency fund i was gonna say you
should have 10k but before we go to that
we gotta thank our sponsor ladder ah
what's wrong i want to help protect my
wife financially if anything bad were to
ever happen jack you don't have a don't
push it graham jack you should just get
life insurance with ladder plus with
term coverage being so affordable it
really doesn't make sense not to a
healthy 35 year old man could get his
family a million dollars in coverage for
only 35 dollars a month you can get
ladders easy to apply for and affordable
life insurance coverage from the comfort
of your own home in just a few minutes
just sign up from your phone or laptop
and ladders smart algorithms will let
you know instantly if you're approved
and life insurance only gets pricier as
you age so now is a better time than
ever to cross that off your list there's
no hidden fees and you can cancel it
anytime you want and if you change your
mind in the first 30 days you could get
a full refund so go to ladderlife.com
iced coffee to get your free quote today
ladderlife.com iced coffee thank you so
much ladder and back to the podcast you
know we do a lot on this podcast what
talk about my unfortunate misadventures
or whatever oh you're dating life with
girls yeah and i think it's time to flip
the script and talk about you guys
because i know that your current
significant others aren't necessarily
the first ones that you've had right
uh right no comment i don't know i have
no comment so you
don't want to open up about this stuff
however it's expected that i do because
you're if you're you're dating that's
why but you've had no i'm talking about
graham i think it's fair
it's fair what do you want to know how
many offenses
wow this is spicy zero zero to ten
zero to ten zero to ten so nine
[Laughter]
so like zero nine and a half
zero to ten okay when do you have your
first girlfriend uh
17
and why did you like about her oh god i
mean a lot of things she was great
really nice uh same interest very smart
she's very book smart like a straight a
student i was not
so what do you think she liked in you oh
man i was uh uh
i was in the band i was in the band i
was in the basement i was in a man
or like a rock band a rock band
i was in a band the school band oh
the band uh i played drums
and you thought that was attractive to
her
yeah so yeah we mentioned
shows she did yeah and and how did you
ask her out
uh
oh oh you know what this is this is
actually uh how it came to be i actually
that's a funny story we all went to a
friend's house and i they were trying to
set me up with this this other friend
her name was olivia and they're trying
to set me up with her and i went on one
date with olivia so far and i don't
think she liked me at all and i took her
to the cheesecake factory
man
uh i brought my own
drink to pour in the water and we split
something we oh we had this thing we'd
go to the cheesecake factory dishes or
something and split the nachos so like
we'd leave at like twelve dollars or
something like it was really cheap
uh so we did that i don't think she
liked me at all and then this was the
second day we were
having like a whole bunch of friends
over for a movie night
and uh olivia came
and uh
we just we're not hitting it off
or you know i was just like kinda into
her but i don't think she was into me at
all
and uh anyway we we're all in a group
and uh i had on that like the flip phone
back then my screen like the the
background of the screen was a lotus it
was a yellow lotus and i flipped it up
and then uh
this other girl over at said wait a
second is that a lotus i'm like
i'm like yeah it's low she's like oh
that's my favorite car and like you know
lotus and we started talking and then
uh i just basically went from olivia to
the
who became my girlfriend
and and how did you ask her out how long
did you know her before asking her out
um i don't think we ever i i don't think
i ever asked her so it's just kind of a
gradual yeah yeah well what happened i
left something at the house
and then she said oh well we could just
meet up tomorrow and you you know i'll
give it to you then
and then was it yeah
no no it was a friend house but she was
yeah she was she was spending the night
there and she's like oh we could just
meet up tomorrow and and how long did
you guys date for
a year and a half i think so wow so yeah
almost two years a year and a half
almost what led to the
the end of it oh man multiple things
first of all i
got really into real estate and i just
became i was
i was just like
very narrow-minded very like just
shallow when it came to stuff like when
i started going to real estate it just
created this huge separation between
like what i was used to and like heist
because she was a year below me and so
she was in high school when i started
doing real estate and once i got in that
whole like working phase
i could i just like
i couldn't relate
to the the high school mentor i totally
like i couldn't do it and so she'd want
to go and like and nothing bad but like
hang out with her friends
on a friday night or a saturday and we
we were all like in the same friend
group but i would go there and i would
just be like miserable hanging out with
her friends and
and they were the same but i like i was
the one that that had changed and i just
go there and be like this is so stupid
uh why are they talking about this none
of this stuff matters and i was just
like
i was so used to everyone else like in
real estate you wouldn't tell her that
though that you weren't having fun i i
think i did i probably made her life
hell
um
nope i i yeah i probably put her in some
really bad positions normal stuff that i
just i couldn't get into and i couldn't
fake it and she could tell that i was
not having a good time and i think it
put her in a bad position because like
her friends could also tell i don't want
to be there and then
uh you know i think a lot of times i was
like i just want to leave let's go and
it's like that's terrible say that to
her i think so
i i told you man i told you but
you know
i'm pretty sure i did or i would be like
okay well what time can we leave how
about we leave it this time
and it was bad it was bad
um
all right yeah so anyway but but then
when she was going off to college i
think there was something that she went
to that um
oh you know what it was she went off to
she invited me to go with her and some
friends to like something and i said i
didn't want to go
that was totally you didn't want to go i
would say oh she asked why
uh
i just say no you're gonna have i think
in my mind i'm like she'll have fun with
her friends and stuff like that like i
don't need to be there but i didn't want
to be there i thought you know oh she'll
have a good time on her own
uh but i think she wanted me there
and um
yeah then after that
uh we had we had the talk
after that
did you cry oh it's um
afterwards i did i think during it i was
just kind of like
kind of like in disbelief a little bit
be like no uh-uh like she'll come back
right she'll change her mind
she instigated the breakup yeah she did
yeah
have you ever broken up with any of your
girlfriends or have you only been broken
up yeah yeah that was my that was my
only breakup
wow yeah
and then you went full real estate grind
mode then i went real sick i mean that
worked out
it worked out so in the end like you
know i i i made so many mistakes with
that that like i won't repeat the same
mistakes i try not to spoke to her
anytime in the last like five years uh
maybe five years ago four years ago i've
probably
it would have been at least like
probably five four years ago or
something like that
yeah but not like spoken spoken i think
this was just like over facebook yeah
yeah i think it was just oh you know
what she got married and i think i just
i sent her and this was like a genuine
like hey uh because because it we had so
many mutual friends that it would come
up on my facebook feed i just said you
know hey hope all's well i just want to
say congratulations hope you don't just
just an innocent sort of thing and she
responded back oh thanks you know blah
blah and that was it good oh
yeah so yeah i didn't expect that
all right
either die
alex i want to know about your first
girlfriend
my first girlfriend like like your first
more serious one okay so i've only had
one serious girlfriend other than my
wife
and that was in high school okay so i
dated this girl for six months and what
do you like about her she was into like
nerdy stuff like me like we both like
harry potter uh we both liked you know
like video games so it was similar
interests she probably liked the same
thing about you yeah exactly we were in
high school and
i just think we got into like
it's so weird to explain but we got into
like the same routine like like
literally like after high school i would
go to her place
just hang out till
whatever nine
go home
and that was life that was life and you
guys didn't like that you were stuck in
a rut that there was no progression of
the relationship or maybe it caused you
to like live very still lives
i don't know it was really weird so she
broke up with me and but it was really
weird because um
there were no i'm a really easygoing
person there were no like problems um
but it
for me it was like all of a sudden like
like we came home on the bus because
we're in high school and like she just
looked off and then we got to her house
and then you know we had the talk
and um
it was just very odd because like the
week before everything was normal it was
like super odd
super odd yeah
i i to be honest i don't even know were
you heartbroken
oh yeah i cried so much yeah my parents
picked me i had to call my parents
i wish she told me before we took the
bus home
she was probably just nervous yeah she
broke up with me and i was heartbroken
and then i met kelsey about uh
probably a year and a half later in
another high school because i moved
and
kelsey actually was the one who came on
to me which if you guys don't know
kelsey is my wife now
and um i did not date kelsey because i
was a uh
i could not relate to anybody in high
school like kind of like how graham was
saying i was running my wedding business
um when i was like 16
and everybody was making plans to go to
college and
i'm like why am i going to get into a
relationship now i'm working on building
this business like what if i develop
feelings for this girl and then she goes
to california like i'm like so i told um
kelsey in high school i was like i can't
you rejected her yeah basically and she
would always ask like i felt so terrible
because like she'd always ask like why
and i'm just like
like i just i'm not into like she
thought it was her and i'm like it's not
you i'm just like
in my head space like i'm not in the
right head space to be dating
and um i'm so glad i did that because i
mean you never know right like what if
we dated in high school and then we
broke up or whatever
and so yeah we i reconnected with her
later and she became my wife that's
crazy but there was an error in my life
where i was like jack
single you know going on casual dates
and stuff i wouldn't say that
what would you call them yeah what did
you call them rendezvous
rendezvous rendezvous
hanging out in the hot tub with your
roommates or yeah i hang out in the hot
tub with my roommates yeah all right no
i don't really go on but i learned matt
that's when i learned magic
yeah and i'm sure that like attracted
like that was like dude i thought it was
the nerdiest thing ever
yeah
it wasn't it was
when i learned magic first of all people
thought it was stupid and then like once
you learn like cool stuff then you
immediately like everybody goes up to
you like could you do the thing like i'm
like like okay
and uh yeah i did take i i picked up
this girl at the mall i was like hey
like you're really cute you picked her
up at the mall yeah i was like magic i
was like what time yes i was like hey i
was like what time is your shift over
she said like 8 p.m and i was like okay
i'll be back here at 8 p.m and i went
and i picked her up and then we went on
this date i knew nothing about it was
fun and then
uh then she even told me uh she had two
kids
and we were like 19 or something yeah or
something or 18 i forgot how old i was
yeah and uh i was like oh like that's
okay and then i took her on the second
date and i took her and her kids out it
was like
how old were you i was like in like 18
19.
and she was there but they loved the
magic tricks and then i think she just
wanted you to perform i didn't do the
magic tricks
no but then um
you know after like going out you know
on a date and she had her kids and stuff
like she was nice but like
i was just that we were in different
completely different phases in my life
yeah yeah so this is jay bae he's a part
of the private mentorship group that we
host and i just developed a relationship
with him over the two years he's been in
the group and he is very smart in real
estate investing stock market investing
so much and he was such an outlier in
the group that we decided to have him on
because he was in vegas and he's going
to tell a couple crazy tenant stories
because he has some really good ones so
let's just hear about this shenanigans
that he's had with his tenants and uh
yeah well good to meet you all right so
uh tell us the story i'm curious i'm
really curious i know nothing going into
this book knows nothing i know most of
it and it's it's wild yeah so there
those are documented pretty well on my
channel um i've had a few properties
completely destroyed
which
i think that would suggest that my
screening process needs some work
but i'm learning getting better you
think that's the solution
i mean
kind of
i mean i want to own responsibility for
selecting the wrong tenant of course but
sometimes you really just don't know
especially when you're renting to a
section 8 tenant
and my first inclination when i started
investing in real estate was i got to do
section 8
and i think one of the things that drew
me to section eight is that when you
when you're first starting out you don't
really know how to do the analysis you
don't know if the numbers are gonna work
you're thinking
i don't know how much rent i can get for
this property but i'm gonna sign a
mortgage and i know i'm gonna pay x
amount of dollars i'm really not sure if
i'm going to get that much rent
but with section 8 they'll tell you how
much you're going to get paid it's right
on their website the payment standards
so then i was able to say oh i can get
this and it's going to cost me this this
is great i feel confident and it kind of
let me feel good about signing these big
stacks of mortgage papers
but when you get into section 8 renting
to section 8 tenants it's tricky because
there there are good tenants and there's
bad tenants of course like any market
but it's a little bit more difficult to
find the good section 8 tenants and i
think because
the things you would normally look for
in a good tenant you're not going to
find within the section 8
applicant because if they had like a
great job and tons of money and
a great credit score
they probably wouldn't need assistance
in the first place
so you're down to like oh well
it's pretty good it's not that bad of an
application but you have to kind of go
with your gut
and i've had a couple people like i felt
really good about them they were nice
people
everything seemed well
and then nope they destroyed my property
like really badly what they do i had one
tenant that was living there
um prior to the pandemic
and then when the pandemic happened i
didn't do the inspections
so normally i do like several
inspections a year to see how things are
going
and section 8 actually requires an
inspection but during the pandemic they
just said do a self-inspection which
means you you call the tenant
essentially and say anything wrong how
are the smoke detectors there's a little
list and they just answer verbally and
then you're like okay all good so i did
that
nothing was reported
and then the following year came i'm
like okay time to do an in-person
inspection again
and i show up
um and oh my god
so much damage the place was destroyed
there was
the front door had been kicked in the
door jam was broken
the
bathroom had
a flood that was completely destroyed
the vanity and flooded the floor
there the kitchen was
it's just it's hard to explain you would
have to see it it was just so much
waste committed on the property
unbelievable amount of damage
and the tricky part about it is with
section 8
they'll
they'll do some weird things to you like
there are certain things that are
considered uninhabitable
and you have to get them fixed right
away so they picked out a bunch of stuff
after this inspection
and they said you have 24 hours to get
this fixed
i'm like 24 hours so there was like
six plumbing problems like none of the
drains worked the front door didn't
close
and they tell me this
and they
um oh and the funny part is they mail
like snail mail the list of things you
need to fix
but they told me on the phone i had 24
hours to fix it am i the only one not
figuring out the problem here i'm going
to find out in three days that i had 24
hours to fix x amount of things so
anyway they
finally emailed me the list and by this
time it's already like seven o'clock at
night and i'm looking at this going oh
my god
i have to i need like so many people
over here working
so luckily by this time i had already
made pretty good connections so i know
like a lot of contractors and plumbers
and various people
and i'm always really good to my people
by the way
and this is a good reason why like
whenever somebody does work for me
they're like oh it's 200 i'll give them
300
just more than they ask for all the time
and
in this particular example making good
acquaintances because i treat people
well
came back to help me because i had to
call people after hours
and i'm like you're not gonna believe
this but i need all these things fixed
by tomorrow
like really
so they come over i had two contractors
and two different plumbers so four
people working
and we were there till like
12 30 or one o'clock
in the morning and we finally got all
the things fixed on this list
and so
that was just the urgent stuff but then
the inspection team
says all right there's a bunch of other
stuff you have to fix by you got 30 days
or whatever
yeah it was 30 days
and if you don't fix it the property is
going to be abated
and they sent me this sheet and
abatement is a situation where
um
you're not going to get paid the section
8 payment anymore
and you cannot collect the rent from the
tenant for the portion of the missing
rent
so essentially the tenant gets to live
there free
if you don't fix these things it's just
the most unbelievable situation so i'm
thinking the tenant destroyed my
property
and if i don't fix it within 30 days
uh the tenant gets to live there free
and here's the here's the thing too it's
like of course i want to fix the
property i don't want to have a garbage
property or be a slumlord
but this particular tenant already
destroyed it once why would i want to
spend thousands and thousands of dollars
fixing all this damage when they could
potentially destroy it again
and some of the requests seemed really
unreasonable too like
too many weeds in the
backyard well
they're in the least responsible for the
landscaping i didn't cause the weeds to
be there why am i why do i have to fix
that
and
that was the situation i was in so i
fixed all these things anyway and then
this inspector came over and still
failed me i was just like i don't know
what's going on
so the property got abated but luckily i
was able to evict the tenant because i
was working on a side channel
[Music]
with a lawyer to get the tenant out and
it worked otherwise i would have been
screwed yeah
yeah now i had a buddy who had a whole
building of section eight i think it was
nine units in los angeles all of them
were section eight and it had been
nothing but problems he wouldn't
originally think the same thing as you
that it was going to be guaranteed
they were all there
95 of the rent came from the government
and didn't have to worry about it but my
gosh the problems that he had with that
building i mean yes the rent got paid
but
he would receive calls every few weeks
about incidents at the property um there
were like drug deals going on at the
property there's a whole bunch of like
illegal stuff going on the property um
a lot of uh infestations for uh bugs
because
one tenant there in particular was a
hoarder and so section 8 would come
remove it he would fix it but then a
month later the same issue would come
and then there'd be cockroaches
everywhere from the one unit
um yeah it was no he ended up selling it
i had the exact same problem yeah
cockroaches everywhere and
it's not just a sanitation thing but
cockroaches can destroy stuff they get
they
piled up in the stove for example in
such masses that that they
they leave droppings in like poop and
they filled up this stove and it didn't
work anymore
and i sent a repair man like because it
was a pretty new like range
i'm like i don't know why it would be
broken so i sent a repairman and he got
there and he took a picture he's like i
can't fix this this thing's ruined wow
cockroach is everywhere
and what do you do it's like
didn't you have also a tenant that hid a
fish
oh so i haven't told anyone this story
yet i also house hack i mentioned that i
started out house hacking i still house
hack i have tenants right now
living in my house
and normally i want to say it's like 99
a great experience most people that want
to move into a room are just in some
kind of transition they're
they're moving soon or they have a
temporary job or their
whatever
but i i have made some
bad choices and this one tenant in
particular stands out as like the worst
tenant i've ever had to live with
so this guy shows up and he he speaks
well and and it just seemed like he had
good rapport with me he says oh yeah i
work at pixar i'm moving to the area
because i got hired as a digital
animator for pixar which is nearby in
the bay area
and i'm like okay that sounds like a
great job and i'm all impressed
and um
i'm like can i check your references
yeah i'll get that to you but i need to
move in right away cause my job's
starting soon and he had all these like
weird excuses
and i at first i initially agreed that
i'm like i don't like i don't like this
i'm going against my my gut i want to
check three the the references and he
wouldn't let me it feels weird so i
called him back and i'm like you know
what
we're gonna go with somebody else
and he handled it like a champ he's like
i totally understand no problem he was
really mature and responsible about it
and i was talking to my wife i'm like
maybe i judge this guy wrong he handled
that so well so i called him back again
and i'm like i know this is really
annoying i'm all over the map back and
forth but
the room is open again if you want it
and so he moved in and that's
that was the biggest mistake ever you
should never go against your if you have
a bad gut feeling about somebody
i think it's best to stick with that
it's like a red flag
okay this guy moves in
okay
one rule i have in my house is
i don't care if you want to smoke pot or
whatever
just don't do it inside it's pretty much
legal anyway outside just go somewhere i
don't want
hot smoke in my house
so he starts smoking pot in the house
like we wouldn't smell it and he's
tacking blankets up over the door to try
to cover the gaps oh my god so the smoke
won't get out and he's putting
thumbtacks in the ceiling
to try and cover up the vents he just
insists on smoking it in the bedroom and
i catch him one time and i'm like you
can't be doing this but he keeps on
doing it
and he starts making so many holes in
the wall that he decides he wants to fix
the holes and he starts adding layers of
paint because i had some matching paint
in the garage he would go get it and he
started painting over the walls and you
start getting like this thick layer of
paint over the the texture which is
ruining the wall you have to tear all
that off and start over
and finally i had enough because he was
painting the door trim he ended up
messing up and painting over the
hardware it's just the room's getting
destroyed
and i'm like you know what
i've told you multiple times it's in the
lease here's a here's a 30-day notice
because you won't stop smoking pot in
the house
and that's when he lost it he was so mad
so he ended up uh
i have some cameras around the house he
ended up slicing
the wire
and those are pretty expensive to
replace because it was a long one he
sliced the wire to the camera i don't
know why he did that or what he was
thinking but he was kind of mad but i
could actually see him slicing the wire
with another camera that was
cause they're wide angle right yeah so
even though it wasn't necessarily
pointed at him he was in there and i i
found the footage so at first i
approached him like why did you cut the
wire i didn't do it so i showed him the
footage and he's like all right i did it
because you you're evicting me and i'm
pissed off about it and so i changed his
eviction notice from a
30 day to a three day which in
california you might know that's legal
to do if somebody's damaging your
property
[Music]
and then he was just like so mad he's
like i'm gonna do something to make sure
that you go to jail
and he started like um
smashing things and calling the police
so he smashed his room door and told the
police that i was trying to harm him and
the police came over i'm like i told him
everything i'm like here's what's going
on
here's video footage of this guy
smashing his own door like i have
cameras inside i don't know why he
thinks he now you have cameras in his
bedroom no absolutely not that would be
really weird how do you know in the
common area of the common area okay got
it but because his bedroom door is off
the common area it the door gets smashed
from the inside
and then he comes walking out
he thought it would be fine to do inside
the room it was really home when he was
smashing the door
um
i don't think i was home when he was
actually doing so you couldn't hear him
anyways no but but i came home the door
was smashed and he's calling the police
trying to tell them like he thought i
would just get like arrested or whatever
anyway uh
he's finally gonna leave because he has
no choice and he's his efforts to
cause more problems are failing but on
his way out he gets some raw salmon out
of our freezer we buy these like costco
packs of salmon and he hides salmon in
multiple places around the house
and i'm on a business trip
and i'm away for like a week or whatever
and my wife is trying to study she's she
was working on becoming a nurse she's a
nurse now and she's like i'm having the
hardest time studying the house really
stinks
i'm like what do you mean it stinks and
she's like it smells like something died
like this is just terrible you have to
come home
i'm like i smell so bad that i have to
leave my business trip and come home
like yes so i i come home and i'm just
like oh my leave your business trip well
it was kind of wrapping up anyway
so um yeah i came home and
oh my god it smelled
horrible like probably the worst smell
i've ever smelled in my whole life
it was rotten fish
so here's the funny part he hid it in
multiple places but i didn't know that
so i was looking around for this fish
and i finally find some fish
in the laundry room in the back of the
cupboard i'm like okay i solved it and
we throw the fish out
and we're thinking everything's gonna be
fine it was just like residual smell but
it kept stinking and like the next day
i'm like
what is happening
how bad is that fish and we find another
one in the closet i'm like oh god
we have no idea how many pieces of fish
there are in this house this is like
this big treasure hunt
like an easter egg hunt for rotten fish
i mean it was nasty it had maggots in it
wow like
trigger warning it was really bad
but the last piece
was hidden behind the dishwasher that
was the hardest one to find
he took like a piece of fish and he had
a cane
and he pushed it back there
i only found it because i started
reviewing the video to see what he was
up to and i saw him push it back there
so you have footage of him pushing the
salmon behind them yeah wow
yeah so he got that out and then the
smell went away oh geez if i were him i
would have put it in like a vent
or like you know
of course yeah but but you got to put in
an area where you're not going to like
you can't access it easy so like vents
in the drywall
uh you know they're giving so many
potential bad tenants ideas right now
probably
you could tape it underneath the table
so you're like looking terrible
it would eventually drop because it
loses its consistency duct tape
there you go how is it to kick people
out of your own house if you're living
with them is that weird because that was
something
i've always wanted a house hack and that
was something that was concerning to me
it's like i move someone in and then
maybe they start pulling something like
that or they start hiding fish in my
house i'm like yo
quit hiding fish in my house
sorry jack get out and then they say oh
yeah i live here like what are you going
to do and they live in my house and it's
awkward you don't want to see someone
you've already sent the eviction notice
to after you've sent them the evidence
yeah you got to like eat in the common
areas together hang out i've done that
it's really uncomfortable so that's
actually a good point because one thing
i never do with my house hacking is
create like a long-term lease it's
always month to month and the reason why
is because if somebody's unhappy there
i want them to feel free to leave the
worst thing in the world is living with
a person who doesn't want to live with
you
so i i'm not going to try to lock
anybody in so i tell them from the start
like it's month to month but then if you
have to kick someone out i would say at
least in california it's pretty much
normal rental rules they get treated
like a regular tenant so they have all
the same rights
but most people
if they're uncomfortable
if you feel uncomfortable with them
there they also feel uncomfortable being
there and they'll just leave early
themselves i've never had anyone stay
like i hate you i'm gonna stay the full
amount of time
like every time this has ever come up
which is very rare to be honest they
have voluntarily just left that makes
sense i mean most reasonable people
probably just leave yeah jason thank you
so much i really appreciate you making
it cancelling your dinner plans to come
on with us the iced coffee hour i really
appreciate it and i'll link to your
information down below in the
description fantastic thank you thanks
great to be here yeah appreciate it